[Musique]
est-ce que vous savez que le film la
haine de Matthieu Kassovitz a été tourné
à Chantelou les viges c'est Mo tu parles
c'est Mo tu parles me par MO par
effectivement toute les séquences dans
la cité avec les trois personnages
principaux ont été tourné dans la
ville les scènes aussi sur les toits des
immeubles avec scè
et de l'injonction envers la visite du
maire vas-y fa pas l'enculer famoi
crédit oh vas-y ta sur je faire crédit
aussi à ta sœur mais comment tu parles
de ma sœur toi arrête de te prendre au
sérieux tu re en
cartonard et d'ailleurs cette année le
réalisateur Matthieu Kassovitz a annoncé
travailler sur une réadaptation de son
film en version comédie
[Musique]
musicale a de
la